the reception for brothers was  overwhelming I'm so proud of the game  and what it's accomplished  I'm very excited to announce his light  studios haze light is a studio that I  have started together with the core team  of brothers and I'm really looking  forward to creating new experience  creation of new IP is the lifeblood of  our industry he is investing a lot of  resources and energy towards new IP  right now Joseph have prudence of not  only to be a great movie director but to  be equally strong game's creator his new  ID and concept is unlike anything I've  ever seen  copper that with a very talented  development team and the support that EA  can give and I think we have something  very special I would love to show  something from the new game but we are  so early in production however we have  put together a very short teaser to give  you some kind of idea on what we're  working on enjoy  you